E
aí
galera aqui quem fala é o melhor de ímã
mais ou menos hoje o blog vai começar
com fumo grande vou mostrar para vocês
aqui ó ó
tá gelada para [ __ ] gelada para
[ __ ] não vou tomar banho não hein eu
hein galera antes de começar o vídeo eu
quero falar uma coisa muito legal para
você a novidade galera é essa caneca
Olha que legal eu vou falar para vocês
as funcionalidades que ela tem se liga
ela vem galera olha com essa com essa
esse negócio e segurar aqui para não
queimar a mão na hora que fosse segurar
Olha aí se você quiser ter essa caneca
clica no link para cima aí Segue esses
25 perfis não vale marcar famoso em aqui
para ele como sempre né o meu irmão
Gabriel olha jogando Olha o
E aí ó Galera eu posso garantir ele não
tomou banho também porque tá frio e eles
não toma banho não
nunca galera nunca vi
[Música]
já
comeu espanhol e não pode jogar mas aula
para o outro poderoso
nunca galera nunca cairão em mundo fala
aí Gabriel
Miche dois fumo agora uma pergunta
filosófica logo de manhã pergunta é essa
Gabriel Como assim
[Música]
é
como se chover ícone aqui
mais seu quiche perto ele é um jogo de
jogo habilidades antes alguns
personagens explicado de personalidade
forte alguns eu adoráveis e de caráter
como o botão né é o que eu gosto
personagem que eu gosto
de uma mente aberta
por favor Deus nem fantasia Entendi
então nem uma coisa muito legal e as
bactérias desenvolver Imagine só muito
legal legal ó galera vou mostrar mais
gente da Família com a minha irmã uma
malha galera aqui é a Ana
o velho você vai filmar malhando Olha a
vida de blogueira Fit não é fácil hein
cara deixa eu terminar aqui ó cê é louco
nem avisa mano ela malha para carai
não é só olha para [ __ ] eu trabalho
com isso aí Fluence a dor aqui ó
tô preparando em vou chegar
Olímpia Você está louco Gabriel falou
que ia malhar comigo não apareceu velho
cadê o Gabriel Gabriel tá lá em cima lá
o game 1
e
aqui Vou terminar aqui eu vou jogar
alguém te pede Ah mano sei lá você não
termina nunca esse trem tem o letreiro
aí começa apertou 9 horas da manhã
trabalhando até agora quer jogar depois
que o irmão mais novo geralmente irmã
mais velha nem com o irmão mais novo
fala que pode ser ver com a família
louca o minha vó tá tudo na cozinha vai
lá ver ela lá é louco família é louca
tomou banho tá louco
e eu
E aí
e ai ele olha mais um fumo um grande
aqui que não dou banho mano que grita
Dress Up
Oi Mano que é isso vó e
E aí
vou tomar um banho quente Caiu essa
merda merda cão e 400 gata miserável com
os outros
problemas quer que eu espere
chegar para poder tomar um banho quente
eu vou esquentar isso aqui Vem logo para
cá
Olha aí tá vendo fumo zero minha vó um
sempre dá um jeito é não vou hi-fi hi-fi
hi-fi
E
aí a
minha by Ray
nessa casa você esquece o tempo que tá
no fogo essa árvore que tá perdendo 20
quando a gente tem que no chão mãe
evaporou tudo o outro quer ficar
filmando a soltura da casa enquanto não
quer jogar videogame figurado em cima é
uma ótima é um morcego é o que a outra
que amanhã lá fora fica filmando aqui no
Brasil tá vendo aí tu tudo cada um
chuveiro em falar que o Gabriel aqui ó ó
em Portugal não foi
jogando bem nichipet aí eu não recomendo
muito você baixar esse jogo para viver e
criar olha aí olha aí vivenciar o que
Gabriel
os
compressores eu gostei não tem uma coisa
que ele parece que está dando trabalho
é o que eu sempre jogo sempre fazer
Gabriel acho que a vovó queimou
Então galera a gente vai ficando por
aqui eu vou socorrer minha avó ali que
ela se queimou acho no banheiro se você
gostou então você vai clicando já não
gostei no like aí comenta aqui embaixo
qualquer coisa que você quer ver aqui e
a isso galera sozinhas vol 1 E aí
[Música]